c'est l'équipe de france de football
s'envole cet après midi pour la pologne
match très important car les français ne
sont pas qualifiés pour l'instant pour
la poule finale de la prochaine coupe
d'europe les français y croient
yann lavoix hervé pozzo reportage
jacquet et son groupe car c'est bien
d'un groupe dont il faut parler
désormais aimé jacquet y tient
énormément pour ce match contre la
pologne il a donc rappelé la jeune garde
nantaise pedros ou edec 42 les stars qui
évoluent à l'étranger en le mât cantona
et desailly et alou pour le boeuf convié
lui à venir apprendre c'est cela le
groupe jacquet j'ai essayé surtout de de
donner tout de suite une certaine
assurance à tout ce groupe là je lui et
je lui fais entièrement confiance et je
lui donne la possibilité
de poursuivre son chemin voilà l'idée un
petit peu directrice de ce match contre
les boulonnais dugarry est venu
remplacer look blessé peut-être
sera-t-il aligné aux côtés de pedro
c'est du web des quotas
hoebeke promu avant centre de l'équipe
de france malgré son jeune âge et sa
performance plutôt moyennes face à la
roumanie
il y avait eu quelques ratés je vais pas
m'arrêter parce que j'ai loupé des
occasions c'est pas du tout dans ma
nature jean loup près d'autres j'en ai
loupé avec nantes ça ça me ça me touche
pas beaucoup
ce qui me touche plus tôt c'est que
l'équipe de france ne l'a pas gagné
voilà c'est passé pas mon cas personnel
qui est jaked donne de la voix conseil
dit dirige
c'est vrai son équipe n'a pas marqué un
seul but en deux rencontres il faut que
cela change mais aimé jacquet est
confiant d'ailleurs il a le sourire un
sourire communicatif